what is going on there reject nation
we're at cinemark right now talking into
our phones for better audio because we
don't have lav bikes like how much
professional people do love coming to
cinema to watch these movies i mean guys
look just just follow me and follow me
with these cameras let's do a little
circle here look how beautiful
everything is we love it here so much
that we agreed to do a giveaway a
giveaway that's right congrats and thank
you to everybody who entered because we
got a lot more submissions what are
their names expected and the four
winners as of now unless there's some
reason we can't be too loud in here
there are people watching movies be
respectful to cinema underscore d786
persons underscore username 63
presley.rise or reese and bastienne
underscore saucy now you guys go enjoy
yourselves yeah a good delicious
cinnamon movie yeah make sure you tag
cinemark and thank them for the
experience and don't sell them and if
you do sell them back to us yes we'll
buy them we will buy them for a higher
price than you got them for
all right guys so we just saw halloween
kills and you know
what i think i went in with the exact
right expectations for this movie i
watched the the original not the
original watch the last halloween
i watched the previous halloween uh
again yesterday which i i really like a
lot i think i like them more the second
time watching it and then going in to
this one you know i saw what people i'm
not gonna lie to you guys thought
everyone was saying around tomatoes i
read all the capsules i was too curious
to know what they had to say right it
did prep me exactly for the experience i
was walking into i gotta say you know
when you see something that's like a 58
and you're hearing all the common
criticisms for it and then you watch it
i was like actually this was better than
what i was like i don't think it's as
focused as the first halloween movie is
like the or the previous one you know
how this talk goes 2018 2018 what had a
really solid like build-up to michael
myers versus laurie strode it has a
certain type of like personality to it
where there's a natural kind of fun that
movie is having this one has a bit more
of a darker more grim approach to it and
there's a lot of things thematically
they want to explore because they've got
like a bunch of different characters
they're focusing on this time and lori
strode is actually kind of taking a bit
of a back seat this time around she is
not doing so well due to injuries she's
sustaining so she's kind of just in the
hospital a lot and there's a much bigger
cast of characters going on in here the
characters you focus on way more here
than you do even laurie strode it's more
violent honestly before going into any
more specifics i'll say that by the end
of it i like it more than rob zombies
halloween too so it's a pass for me
sure
all right yeah i did a dig up that just
for john i'm not gonna fight you i know
that i am in an uphill battle with
halloween too yeah this was an odd
experience i think uh and i didn't read
as much but i did read a little bit
beforehand the main thing that struck me
about this movie is how torn it left me
feeling because the tone is still pretty
naturally on par with the first the
previous movie and the way that they're
trying to infuse those you know
lingering 70s stalkery shots with a more
modern you know grim and rough
sensibility yeah i liked almost all the
themes they were going for and i thought
that kind of the further the movie got
the more chaotic and muddy everything
became and i feel like in some ways that
complements the actual action and themes
that are happening in the story but as a
viewing experience certain elements of
the plot started to plateau and get
repetitive in a way that it doesn't help
a slasher movie and that isn't
repetitive in the way slasher movies
maybe ought to be i liked a lot of the
different performers and stuff like that
there are a lot of really cool gore
effects and things like that it is yeah
like i think michael is best when he is
in a grim and mean and angry kind of
movie this definitely has that i just
wish that it could have maybe paid a
little more mind to its characterization
of a lot of the characters and let them
breathe by a certain point in the movie
there's just a common slogan monologue
catchphrase everybody starts to say and
it does become kind of cartoony and
there are elements of the overall action
that i could really feel the third movie
forcing a kind of pulled punch on for
lack of a better way to phrase that they
have a good setup for the third one to
make it feel even more personal i'd say
well my favorite part of this movie was
like the last 10 or 15 minutes that was
like when everything really coalesced
and i was like this is the sequence i've
been waiting for this whole movie and i
wish the rest of the movie didn't feel
like it had to pull so many punches to
get there because the tone is like way
more menacing than some of the actual
realities being depicted on screen
that's so fascinating to me because they
have a few things going on here that i
really did like as you see in the
trailer the town of haddonfield is
really rising up against the boogeyman
this time around and there are plot
points there that i've i feel like
people in
the greater los angeles area might be
conflicted in when you look at it
through that lens you're like this is
kind of ridiculous i feel like anyone
who's ever i've never lived in a small
town city but i've known a lot of people
who've lived in small town cities and i
imagine and and i heard it from even the
people i had the thought validated from
many people on our screen today if
you're from a small town city this is
99.9 likely how they're gonna behave and
react and i really like how they played
into like the mob mentality the horde
mentality and how that feeds into like
the evil begets evil mentality too they
even have like these other plot lines
here like weirdly the the main character
to me if i were to try to pinpoint the
main one it would be the character of
tommy who's back here he seemed like he
was it was more about him than it was
about even laurie this time around he
seems to be like the the protagonist is
really leading the charge and without
going going into spoilers here there's a
there's a couple who's living in a very
familiar house right now and i thought
they were
weirdly enjoyable i do think though that
i really thought was repetitive and a
bit like annoying it seemed like every
scene other than maybe one was just all
talking about michael myers like every
scene is just about michael myers and
like the dialogue never felt like not i
wouldn't say never there are parts where
they get more explorative with it and
they do enhance the movie but a lot of
times it just feels like you're either
recapping a bunch of things i already
know by now or you're kind of just
reiterating things i've heard a
gazillion times in this movie alone
already they establish a cycle where
there's this kind of scene that does to
me feel like it keeps repeating where
it's like the build to a crescendo and
the movie needs to hold that crescendo
there's so many scenes where you get the
intense monologue that feels like it's
about to lead to a big action everybody
steps up and has their moment to go it's
been 40 years michael's been terrorizing
this town well no more it ends tonight
evil dies tonight and like so many
people get that monologue and scenes
that are all built to emotionally
resonate the same kind of way which is
we're taking it to the streets except we
keep building to taking it to the
streets like multiple times throughout
the movie and then it takes a while to
actually feel like we really
got there in a way that's cathartic and
that you know matches i feel like if
they had swapped out some of those writ
large monologues for things that were
more personal built upon the
relationships shared by people in these
small towns that could have been nicer
and maybe expounded upon some of the
characters we don't know as well as the
beloved ones yeah well it's because
they're exploring some new themes here
and they're also introducing a bunch of
characters they're reintroducing a bunch
of characters on top of that and of
course you gotta amp up the the thrills
and the kills and all that i mean one
element to this movie that i really
thought was actually missing was that it
really wasn't scary at all and it felt
like it wasn't even really attempting to
actually be scary it was kind of tense
um but i was more like fascinated than
it was actually like finding things
really tension filled or scary here's
the thing though what i found very
interesting watching this movie with the
previous halloween my favorite parts are
easily jamie lee curtis and michael
myers easily my favorite parts and in
this one
my favorite character michael myers
it was it was actually interesting to
watch because i was like every time he's
on screen i am gripped by this like i
think they've done such a good job in
this franchise freaking michael myers
has this quality to him that often gets
kind of made fun of because he is
technically a human being yet he has a
supernatural aspect and thematically
this franchise seems to slowly be
building him up into the supernatural
entity arena the way we build him up in
our mind and how that kind of manifests
into a real physicality for michael
myers what i wish this movie had was
that other just protagonist counterpart
that brought the balance for michael
myers to the point of how like that the
previous one brought a laurie strode
like that's our hero that's our villain
you know yeah and then here i was like i
really love the villain there's not
really a protagonist i'm in love with it
it would have been nice to have a true
counterweight or counterpart to him
because michael is yeah like the dark
core the ground way more violent way
more violent yeah it's violent and nasty
it's disgusting you know it's intimately
mean sometimes it's fun sometimes it's
just disturbing yeah yeah i mean it's
pound for pound if you if you just want
the kills and you want the menace and
the grid it's definitely got that stuff
[ __ ] you know uh i i give it a pretty
solid recommendation
yeah i see it it's all right like i i'm
more it's weird i feel very torn but i
still have a good time yeah i'm not so
torn i think it's i think my
expectations were just set just right
for it gave me what i expected and it
gave me what i wanted there are things
that i wish they did infuse more but
honestly i think for a part two to a
slasher movie especially after watching
the previous one and then going into
this one i think it's a really solid
second chapter and i feel like they
actually have a really good direction of
where they want this trilogy of the
halloween films to go especially by the
way this movie ends i'm under the
impression that they do a good job with
part three they'll actually make part
two even better so hopefully i'm under
the impression i'll do that so honestly
i think it's a really good second
chapter whereas i feel like the first
one felt like a good complete film this
feels like a middle chapter to something
bigger i'm i'm weirdly uh i'm all for it
i quite i quite enjoyed it i don't know
i like these more than uh the ones
before to be honest with you guys
that's ultimately the thing i'm torn on
is whether or not like
if halloween ends doesn't come out and
and make some of the things i griped
about in this one a little better than i
will know ultimately so yeah it's weird
there are things that just don't feel
like they'll be complete until the next
one yeah
what are you gonna do
thanks so much for being here check out
cinemark subscribe to halloween kills
and evil dies tonight